[موسيقى]
كان الوباء
بالتأكيد محركًا
لأروع إبداعاتي ،
حسنًا ، كهف الجليد هو منطقة المتعة الخاصة بي ،
شجري الآمن ،
إنه مكان يمكنني
الاسترخاء فيه والاستمتاع
بخيالي
، الكهف الجليدي هو منزلي ولكن عليّ أن
أدير منزلي  في
مكان يمكنني فيه أيضًا القيام بالعمل ولكن
بطريقة غير رسمية جدًا ،
لذلك عادةً ما أصنع الآيس
كريم
الخاص بي لأكون صادقًا ، وأعتقد أن النكهات الأكثر غرابة التي
صنعتها
مؤخرًا هي الآيس كريم اللذيذ
[موسيقى]
من جواكامولي إلى بيستو إلى الطماطم
السبانخ الكريمي بالفلفل الحار بارميجيانو جورجونزولا
سمها الكزبرة
والبروكلي ، قوام الآيس كريم هو الذي يمكنني القول أنه تم
التلاعب به بطريقة طبيعية لإعطائك
عامل التجريف هذا أو عامل النعومة
للآيس كريم العادي ولكن بدون
سكر
وهذا هو الأكثر تعقيدًا  الجزء
الأول طورت ثلاثة مفاهيم مختلفة
وهي الآيس كريم المتقلب المزاج
لذا يُطلق على أحدها
ابتهاج وكل شيء يتعلق بالسعادة ، لذا فهي تقود
سعادتك إلى مستويات أعلى
فقط باستخدام المكونات  لقد
أثبتنا علميًا أننا نرفع سعادتك
لأعلى ، هناك واحدة أخرى تسمى
تنشيطي وهناك واحدة أخرى تسمى اتصل بي
والتي
تدور حول تقشعر لها الأبدان
[موسيقى
] لم أعرض أي آيس كريم لأي شخص
قبل أن أكون سعيدًا بذلك  لذلك
في تلك اللحظة أريتهم
وعادة ما أحصل على عهود
خاصة مع النكهات غير العادية